oh
that spinny logo thing can only mean one
thing it's time for fat man beyond i'm
kevin smith i'm mark bernard
hey hey
show's about to begin [ __ ] it already
began we've been long debating certain
things
but we'll not say out loud no that was
happening before the show but
this thing's up which means the show is
about to happen
it's the only time they put up blue site
other than like when you're building a
bank so put up the partition please
yeah this is uh where this is not how me
and mark feel about each other
it's just a sign of the times kids just
like prince told us many years ago
um this will mark the eons
like mark the show in time you could be
just watching the show
with the sound off i don't know why
you'd want to do that because it's not
very visually around such a dynamic
andrew does a great job switching the
cameras but even with the three cameras
it's not a visually arresting show like
how do you match cut they're just
standing there
that being said uh you'll be able to if
you were just
leafing through them on some digital uh
platform of the future apparently not
quibby
um you will see this partition and be
like that was during the covid
well i want to be optimistic and say a
year but could be decade
could be hopefully not you know and
you'll be able to know like we will
ceremoniously when we get to drop this
for real
it's gonna be a night that's that's true
you know how they
raise a [ __ ] banner like when they
retire a hockey jersey or something
we're gonna make a big [ __ ] this
place can be packed and we're gonna use
the scissors
to simultaneously cut those strings to
throw off the shackles of that
it'll say mission accomplished
and the mission will be nowhere near
accomplished but we'll do it anyway this
is accomplished
underlined we beat coven and we as
triple underline
meaning us right here breathing free
um until then this is going on
but indeed that ain't gonna stop the
news this will stop the spread of germs
between me and mark i'm talking about
this [ __ ] like it's the first time it's
been up
it's been up for like six months at this
point
uh this may stop germs from going back
and forth but it ain't gonna stop the
news from coming back and forth
no and that's why i came here tonight
rushed out apparently in my [ __ ]
bathrobe
you can tell i'm fast giving up i'm just
like you know what this is fine
free show that's a free show i says to
myself i was like
nobody's expecting me to dress up if i'm
comfortable in this
i'm wearing this i was laying around the
house watching
uh this is so [ __ ] up it's kind of
tied to our show
so remember we talked about there was
like a spanish uh
like genre superhero netflix
on netflix so i went and found it
because i said like we're gonna i'm
gonna watch it
and i assumed you'd watch it but i don't
did you didn't
didn't spoke for myself any event i went
looking for it and i'm sorry
and my wife was there and i was like ooh
can we watch this cause i said that i
was gonna watch this and she was like
what is it
and i was like um it's it's subtitled
which she watches a [ __ ] ton
of subtitle programs she watches all the
crime shows from around the world
so she constantly reading programs so
the way i knew she would react poorly to
it being a genre thing
so i but i but i figured if i went in
with like it's subtitled that makes it
classy a little bit right
and so uh i was like all right it's
subtitled she said what is it
i was like it's a superhero thing she
i'm not watching that come on
and i went to show it to her and she
goes look i love reading stuff
like i'm not gonna read about
superheroes uh she was like what's the
one right there
and it was it's called money heist
have you seen it i haven't i've i've
heard of it
terrible title well terrible american
title the name of the show it's from
spain
um uh espana mark i don't know if you've
ever heard of this place
oh that [ __ ] i love that because
throughout the whole show
like you know they oh my god they speak
so fast so rapidly
but every once in a while you just hear
the lift come in
where they're like polo you know
and they hit the so hard it's like
skidding like
it's like a race car going fast hitting
oil it's like going polithia and then
right back on track
so cool um stylized with an edge of its
life
it's the story of a bank heist
somehow they got [ __ ] two seasons out
of this [ __ ]
had they stolen the money yet yes
spoilers but then they got another two
seasons
they got another two seasons out of
another [ __ ] heist
like when those two like i couldn't
believe the end of season one they
didn't
wrap [ __ ] up they were like [ __ ] it keep
coming back and i came back because it
worked because i worked it
and so i watched all of it and they
finished the story and i was like all
right it's done
and then they [ __ ] started again with
a brand new heist which i was just like
two episodes into before
i came here i got rooked into it because
it said four parts so i'm like all right
four hour long episodes i can [ __ ] do
this this will be great and it'll be
like she won't watch the superhero show
so i'll you know if she'll watch this
great we're [ __ ] we've saved our
marriage
so we'll watch this with reading four
parts
means four [ __ ] seasons so we're
watching like part one
and all of a sudden it's like going
beyond ten episodes i was like what the
[ __ ] happened
and then realize it's just it's four
seasons of the show so we've been
so pop committed the real name of the
show in spain
is um what is it la
papel no acosta la casa del papel
paper house no okay because they brought
they go what is it house of paper paper
house
andrew uh because they uh they go to a
mint
it's a brilliant little heist thing
because they go to a mint i i mean
do i spoil let me just spoil a little
bit it's not a big spoiler but
they go to a mint to make
money that doesn't exist so their
philosophy is like we're not robbing
we're not taking
anything okay we're going in they're
taking the building
and it's a big like [ __ ] scam and
[ __ ]
but they're printing brand new money
that
is then they're gonna they can change
all the serial numbers and then get the
[ __ ] out
all right counterfeiting but but not
counterfeiting because it's
legi that you're literally at the place
that makes money and at one point the
dude makes his rationale clear where
he's like look
you know in 2011 or whatever they just
printed
brand new [ __ ] money and just called
the cash infusion like
there's no rules whatsoever what did
they do they gave it to the banks what
the banks do they didn't give it to
anybody they gave it to themselves so
he's like you know as far as i'm
concerned i'm not stealing anything from
anybody
i'm just making new money just like they
made new money it's really brilliant
it's very very superman three
a little bit a little bit but imagine if
you took zoo man three and stretched it
to four seasons of a show that is so
gripping
that's all i've been doing for the last
like [ __ ] 48 hours and also
10 minutes of conversation in superman
three yeah becomes four
seasons every time that's the man three
yielded not only i'm sure the people
that made this show were like we didn't
get it from superman three
but it also yielded office space as well
the gift that keeps on giving um i've
been deep in it it's good
it's worth checking out money heist
[ __ ] so
damn good i i have been deep into
have you seen any of ted lasso no how is
it
you'll be my first oh dude i i was i was
a little like well how did ted laugh so
i don't get what it is every time i turn
my apple tv
there's jason sudeikis's face looking
kind of doofy with the big mustache i'm
like i don't know what this show is
every person that i've spoken to who's
seen it has become an evangelist for it
because it's i hear andrew in the other
room yes
praise the lord you've seen it too tell
that man
what's the story is it soccer it's it's
a a collegiate
um american football coach um takes a
job
in the uk as the coach of like a premier
league
football team right and so it it sets up
very cleanly as like well here's the
kind of doofy dumb american coming into
the uk
maybe he mixed up the sports he heard
the word football and thought he could
do both things
right um and he's going to make an ass
out of himself and you know
it's culture clash right but it is
the closest analogy i can make to it as
far as a sitcom goes is parks and
recreation
which is leslie knope is the biggest
cheerleader for the goodness of
government that has ever been
especially local government and she
never flags in her belief
that local government can actually make
your life better and
ted lasso believes a hundred percent
that he's a good coach and what makes a
good coach
is making the players better people and
he's like i don't care if we win or we
lose but as long as these guys like
get a little bit better human beings
that's a win
and his his level of undiminishable
optimism
is the perfect thing right now
you know like it is very much the half
hour antidote for what else
you sold me how many episodes um i don't
even know i
want to say it's like 10 10 total half
hour 35 minutes each
the easiest watch i keep saying it
whenever i open apple tv
yeah and jason's jake is in my face but
the casting is great
you know it's it's it is a joy to watch
in a way i did not expect it to be
um i'm you've sold me
i'm gonna go you could sell me on
anything
like my arm is down man i showed up in
the robe i'm ready for
anything no you could sell me on
anything
wow yes we can there you go you thought
you were getting a show
without an ad come on we're not showman
we're salesmen
[Music]
and we're here to sell you something
ladies and gentlemen there is a sponsor
for this here episode of fat man beyond
uh this episode of fat man beyond
sponsored by the good folks that
manscaped
dot com man the lawnmower 3.0 they're
the folks that
made the lawnmower 3.0 if i was smart
i would have brought the lawnmower 3.0
with me today
i would have laid it on the bar turned
it on when it went
[ __ ] like that like in that scene from i
wonder
what what's different from the lawnmower
1.0 and 2.0
power mark are you crazy
1.0 couldn't get get through the [ __ ]
kind of frothy bush
a man like i has but nat 3.0 3.0 that
pubis don't stand a chance
it's like cyclops just zhang just called
american manufacturer because
i'm bald now it's brazilian down there
no landing strip it's virgin smoothie
man because the manscaped
folks came up with the lawnmower 3.0 man
it is uh before we go anywhere their
call to action
you can get 20 off and free shipping
with the code
fat man all one word at manscaped.com
that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscaped.com use the code
fat man let's talk about this about
keeping your
privates shaved sounds so horrible
private benjamin no i guess i shouldn't
put it that way
um manscaping you do it as a 50 i'm 50.
do you do it uh
i i don't a weird question i'm 50. do
you manscaping
right now those two things have nothing
to do with each other why do you ask
i decided to do the second half ball
clean as a kid uh i i use it for my head
yeah not from the balls um you know
that has nothing to do with age and more
like i don't get to go to a barbershop
anymore this came along at the perfect
time for me
because i can't hit the barbershop i
can't sit in the chair yet
and let somebody fondle my head and make
it all nice and smoothly smooth
but you know who can do that 7 000 rpm
motor with quiet stroke
technology that's because their third
generation trimmer features a
cutting-edge ceramic blade to reduce
grooming accidents
thanks to advanced skin safe technology
pioneered by manscape
you're never gonna cut your balls with
the manscaped lawnmower 3.0
have you ever done injury to yourself i
never have and you know what the battery
will last
90 minutes are you kidding like if you
got to shave
your balls somebody else's balls the
mailman's balls
like literally there's like a bag full
of balls and he's shaving you can do it
in 90 minutes
with quiet strokes text some friends
tell them to line up
like a daisy chain you're just going to
go and yeah it's good like shearing them
all like sheep
that's the way i like to shave yeah man
he just
lifts that their dick one way and shaves
look it's like those farming videos you
see where they it really is
it's farming edward scissorhands meets
quiet stroke technology
uh it's waterproof technology as well
which means you can do it in the shower
and let's be honest
probably best place best chance of
privacy
you know and also the cleanup is easier
if you're already in the shower because
falling down yeah if you've got you know
the amazon of amazon's down there
there's going to be a lot of hair
and if you've got the amazon of amazons
why aren't you getting
the lawnmower 3.0 kids trim that junk of
yours
don't be a don't let it be a jungle down
there for heaven's sakes
make a clearing what is it uh don't let
it be a rain forest
let it that's horribly depressing
seriously deforest yourself
that's there it is that's the that's the
new logo dear mesquite you said
feel free to go off script
[Laughter]
deforest yourself for the long border
3.0 from the good folks at manscape get
20
off and free shipping with the code fat
man
at manscaped.com your balls
we're ahead we'll thank you as will we
uh and we thank the good folks at
manscaped man for
taking a little real estate they're
paying for tonight's
can of bud light seltzer black cherry
is the most unlickery liquor there is in
the world man
boys if you want to impress people don't
drink this
until they start paying us we will say
it's the zima of the 21st century i
i get made fun of i told my wife i was
like you know what i had a [ __ ] fat
man the other night
bud light seltzer and [ __ ] and she was
like what's that
i was like it seltzer but it's got booze
in it and she was like what
you drank and i was like yeah cause it
tastes like candy
[Laughter]
give me booze it tastes like candy like
beer tastes like [ __ ] to me
i never grew an adult palette for the
taste of beer i don't care how [ __ ]
like
thick it is be thick as a dick man like
they gave me one of them in ireland
they're like this is the real beer
sonny and i drank it and i'm like what
this is pudding
so i'm not a beer person at all um and
your harder liquors
that don't do it for me vodka just
smells like furniture polish
but if it goes froofy or if it smells
like high
c i'm your man it's like it should have
an umbrella in it
yes that's the kind of drinking i like
to do
drinking that reminds me of a happy
childhood
fruit punch
fresh all right man we got some news we
do have some news
the only reason i came tonight man i
came to hear some [ __ ] news last week
i wasn't paying much attention uh to
life because i was reading the news
right up till the show started so i was
unsurprised the whole episode
this week completely everything's going
to be a surprise it's going to be
it's going to be a whole new world for
you remember one point early in the week
saying do you think we'll have enough
news
for this weekend and then mark laughed
at me because something big happened
so we'll be talking about i'm sure that
many other stories right now as mark
cracks open the [ __ ]
faberge egg of news man just
yeah right nice thank you very james
bond dude does one crack open a fact no
no i mean you could if you crack open a
fabrega there like diamonds inside
it's like more treasure is there another
egg is it like a russian nesting dog
you cut into the cake and something all
the [ __ ] skittles come out oh
why don't you fabricate that [ __ ] man
that sounds good
um before we get into the news proper
yeah um
since we taped last yeah the season
finale
of lovecraft country was pitch
perfect i have been uh trying to [ __ ]
i i would say that it was magical
but i have had magic taken away from me
as for the end of the show so as as a
white person i can't
use the even the term magically it was
wonderful
pitch perfect uh loved it hated to see
it end it uh
hated some of the things that happened
but i'm also
a smart enough discerning viewer to know
that if there's a season two
and they've got magic
if spock can come back you know what i'm
saying like i don't want to spoil
anything but like
ship out of danger
there was a moment where i was like are
they are you [ __ ] kidding me i'm
deeply invested
in this character and then i was like of
course you are and so is everyone else
and j don't forget what literally just
happened
right and what the what the lady just
said
they got the magic now so like there's a
chance
you know as they they didn't just leave
them there they carried them across the
bridge
again don't want to spoil it but i i
they're having a season two um there
there are talks there's been no
no official announcement yeah not yet
but it's
you know they'd be crazy not to don't
don't let them watch them in this one
you know what i'm saying like like
damon's like i'm done
make misha go back to work there's so
much more
they could do like they set up such a
beautifully engaging
[ __ ] world turned d into a [ __ ]
badass at the end how awesome is that
and also
like at one point there you know
remember when he gets the book
and he was just like somebody in a like
an overcoat with a metal arm pushed me
through
like you know what i'm saying i know
what you're saying
so good what'd you think of it um loved
it i i
i was a little less enamored with it
than you were
what
[Music]
ship out of danger it uh it's
it's i i still love the show for what it
is yeah i love the crazy wild reaches
that it made
and i remember early on we were talking
about it that it was a show that seemed
not overly interested in narrative as
much as it was interested in emotional
experience
yes you know and like what it made you
feel at the end of every episode and it
was all kind of like little short
stories that were kind of connected by
this
gossamer thread of plot and i feel like
what kind of happened in the final
episode was
it suddenly then had to be about
narrative again because it wanted to
land this bird right and start
connecting story lines and and resolving
plot threads and all that stuff
and for me it was it didn't
it didn't resonate the same way that
some of the earlier episodes did
um there's a lot of it that i really
really liked but my overall experience
was oh i kind of wish it was like one of
the other i kind of wish it didn't feel
the need
to do this and just be its own thing
again sounds like you needed one of
these i might have needed a lot of those
but um i still am so glad that that show
exists i'm so glad that it got the love
that it got i'm i'm
you know the fact that there's
conversations about a season two makes
me incredibly happy because i'm very
curious
about a how they made season one luckily
hbo is giving us
that look in a creating lovecraft
country
crafting lovecraft country oh well
behind the scenes uh
airing on monday um is yeah a bunch of
it used to be a thing you'd see on a dvd
extra but it's a half an hour kind of
docu special about how now they're like
we need content
that's a show people love it just put it
on the air nobody buys dvds
um so yeah that's gonna be on monday
whatever monday is today's the 24th or
the 26th
i'm in i loved it i thought it was
awesome
um i my tastes are not nearly as refined
as mark's
so clearly still so like oh it's so
impressive it's so
like i'll never be that creative and
[ __ ] like that
um but but you were like i'm taking
notes
i have notes half thoughts
um but yeah i uh if you could go back in
time
if mark had a time machine uh
you know you'd see him stop at various
points through history
while orson welles is big citizen kane
mark would be like i have notes
[Laughter]
i would like to see that that film i'd
like to see that little time machine
it's like hey hey george um
i'm just saying the first half hour is a
little wonky
man and maybe which era
the lucas which which era though which
george the first
acts little wonky that doesn't narrow it
down
talking [ __ ] radio days how are the
ducks star wars
that is just three goals it's me going
back in time and telling george luke
gets his first acts or why that's one
whole movie
that's your sequel once you establish
the idea that you can go through time
and fix movies and [ __ ] like that
it's so charming everyone didn't see it
coming like this is [ __ ] great
you're you're [ __ ] sequel is
just george lucas movies and then people
are like oh [ __ ] maybe he'll do
spielberg and then the next one all
spielberg movies yeah
i uh you'd be like the brit you'd be
you'd have your own [ __ ] thing man
you'd be like a chichen chang or a medea
like you could just have a [ __ ]
franchise you know i had a
meeting on the books to pitch it to
quibby because it seemed like a quitting
show
oh [ __ ] a
hell of a segue b very sorry to tell you
mark i quite like the idea itself
quibby was a quick bite here and gone
question how do you spend a billion
dollars
make something that nobody asked for
this is uh that's i mean
look if anyone's looking to remake
brewster's millions as brewster's
billions
like just have him in ben quibby and
then it's over
yeah it's like wow that's all you needed
to do to lose a billion dollars
i mean listen it's this past week
you know jeffrey katzenberg and meg
whitman who were the sort of
progenitors of quibby uh sort of
announced that they were
turning it all off they were shutting it
down that it was clear
that the grand experiment that was
quibby which they raised something like
two billion dollars
of venture capital money in a rare uh
show of a complete
lack of you who [ __ ]
hubris yes i couldn't believe that they
were like yeah we're done
yeah that took balls i mean it took
balls to be like
guess what we invented youtube expensive
[Laughter]
uh but it took even more balls to be
like look when you're licked you're
licked and we're [ __ ]
licked so goodbye you know and then they
they both didn't blame the pandemic and
totally laid it at the feet of the
pandemic
which was we were counted on people like
being out in the world
and you know commuting and having like
less amount of time and so
this would have been the perfect stop
gap for that don't understand that logic
though like it's not like we stopped
consuming during the pandemic
yeah if anything consumption went the
[ __ ] way
up yeah but even on your phone like you
know i i
just never bought that as a whole like
oh man
like [ __ ] we launched during the
pandemic it's like other than
cost you know because you are asking
people to pay for a service
you couldn't have asked for a more
captive audience than the last six to
eight months right
absolutely you know it it it seems
hubris is a good word for it
in that theoretically there is nothing
wrong with the idea of giving people
short form entertainment no way man
it is youtube it is tick-tock it is it
is having sex with me
very quick quick bite it's over you're
entertained you're like well that was
amusing he jiggled all over and now he's
done
[Laughter]
um but it seems like a the spending the
money to
to kind of redefine the experience of
watching a thing on your phone
suddenly like this didn't really matter
it didn't really matter people didn't
want to be that interactive in that way
with their content
and the content that they were giving
people was not
what the audience they were hoping to
get was looking for
is this real shame because i don't know
what happens now with slugfest
yeah slugfest was the series that um
that i did the narration for the russo
brothers uh
series with the kids who did uh uh bat
uh batman and bill um
it's so great i don't know it was
supposed to debut at the end of
november but they just announced that
december 1st they're [ __ ] shutting
down
yeah they're shuttering their service
december 1st they're returning the money
to the investors
um so yeah i hopefully you know
russo brothers i'm sure most people have
heard of them at this point
they'll be fine i can't imagine they
can't set that up someplace else you
know they were only like eight minutes a
piece so
maybe you put two together i think there
were ten so you got five episodes of a
very [ __ ] cool show right there
plus they've got content they had to cut
to get it to eight minutes so
i think it'll wind up finding at home
because it is so [ __ ] fantastic but
um
yeah man this is um i i honestly like
not unexpected as much as like well i
can't imagine this makes it
i just can't believe that they called
the the body this early
you know what i'm saying i mean even
lots of the press is like well
traditionally
because you have money in the bank they
would have just kept on going like your
average company just spends until
they're out of money and then
shuts it down but these guys were like
well listen this is never going to take
off
and like we have a lot of money and
we should probably give it back and
because we can't really have these
people working for us without
any real initiative for them to work
towards
i mean it's yeah it's ballsy to just say
you know what we [ __ ] up we made a
mistake we're shutting it down
everybody gets their money back
everybody go home happy except for the
people who made shows that nobody will
get to see
unless because part of i think the
problem was they they tried to sell
quibby they were like hey listen does
anybody want to buy it we have 100 shows
that we made nobody was buying nobody
was buying because
a lot of the rights deals for the
content belongs to the creators
which is great quibby didn't really own
anything they didn't really own anything
besides the proprietary technology that
lets you do this a lot
um and it turns out that netflix didn't
want to do this a lot and neither did
hulu or
or disney plus or anybody
so i feel like you're going to see a lot
of these shows repackaged as something
else eventually somewhere down the road
agreed um but but yeah it's just it
it feels as if if you're targeting an
audience
that you know traditionally is on their
phones all the time
then reboots of the fugitive is not the
way
to get that done um
good as it may be but like my 16 year
old kid is not going to watch the
fugitive with
a super old dude to borrow from perhaps
one of the finest
funeral scenes ever recorded
of all the streaming services
that i've encountered in my travels
quibbe's was the most human
that's a word for it
such a shame gone too soon
[Laughter]
quibby we hardly knew you quibby we got
to know you and people didn't care
i'm telling you their uh strongest as
far as i was concerned
they hadn't played their strongest card
yet that [ __ ] slugfest show
is a dream but uh if you can't hook them
in with the golden arm
i don't know what's going on you can't
get them with judge
christie what's her name um no ju what's
not christy uh
chrissy teigen chrissy tegan you can't
pull him in with judge chrissy
no it ain't happening i guess not not
you know chat somebody in chat mentioned
if youtube couldn't get youtube
red to work with cobra kai what did what
chance did quibby have
um do you want to give a shout out to
your the friend sitting next to you
that's not the giant bug
oh we could do that uh my fiancee jen
and look at everybody and you can't
really see because it's blocked by the
table but my
daughter on the way is here also for her
first fat man beyonce
in life life is in this room not this
middle-aged death that stares you in the
face life
also did you bring a baby to a bar we
did
my kind of people boy you'd fit right in
where i came from
land of a thousand bars indeed so yes
r.a.p quibby we hardly knew ye
what a year i mean you know hey you
think you had a bad 20-20
did you lose a billion dollars and you
can [ __ ] tank a major streaming
service
no yeah you're doing fine you're here
you're okay
goodbye quibby goodbye quibby let's pour
one out for quibby
um you know who we should say hello to
why hello we say hello to
bud light seltzer number two shit's
about to take off
you're gonna hear my real feelings on
the death of quibby in a second
um it's your breasts
hey so you know how zack schneider is
making a justice league
uh movie again [ __ ] yeah he is um
and it's like less uh uh movie and more
a tv show
but it's a streaming series now it's
like more parts of it and bigger and
bigger
and you know how like these are less
reshoots and more i'm just making a
movie
yes yeah i mean yeah yes i mean i'm not
intimately involved with the production
but from everything i've
always understood there's a lot to get
in order to make it a movie and so
they're getting it
sounds like they're getting it uh jared
leto
who uh who everyone's favorite joker
everybody's favorite joker
there he is remember that yeah has
joined the quote-unquote reshoots for
the snyder cut
now he was not in bvs
nope nor was he in justice league no he
was in
uh suicide squad indeed
which was set in the zack snyder
universe
indeed so is this counts this makes
sense
sure i mean i um
i mean great i'm all for it man are you
kidding me bring them all in man
you know he he's gonna be in it i don't
know why suddenly i'm sounding like
you know looking elmer fudd or porky pig
he's
he is going to be in it um as is joe
manganiello joe's in it joe manganello
is going to be in it
deathstroke is all star of jane salabab
reboot amongst other things
he's coming back he's coming back um
yeah again it's all like
it's i mean all right here dream scene
because now you've got deathstroke and
the joker
yes and from news reports i've read that
ben affleck is
back on set shooting this week christine
yep perhaps we finally see the crossover
of bat fleck and uh
leto joker and manganello
deathstroke like maybe they're all in a
scene together
that's cool i mean we've never seen that
before
we never have and you know so it's less
finishing scenes
that would make me sign up for it yeah
it's new it's just creating a new movie
um i'm all for it man keep piling them
in there
yeah ben affleck ray fisher and amber
heard are
currently part of the shooting that's
underway um
amber heard was in justice league
correct um
she was for like a few seconds he goes
to get the trident his mom's tried
indeed um you know meanwhile henry
cavill superman and gal gadot's
wonder woman were noticeably absent from
the report
and cavill has exclusively explicitly
told collider he won't be shooting
anything new for the 4-hour hbo max
series
remembering this at one point was a
trilogy
that was then cut down to a two-parter
yes
that was then turned into a single movie
yes which
movie are they making i mean they must
they might be making an unheard of
fourth version of this movie
i mean with four with four separate
hours it sounds like it's going to be
every incarnation of the justice league
in one yeah
at the very least it's probably the
two-parter you know
because if i mean zach doesn't make
short movies so if each one of those was
going to be two hours each then that
times out to your four hours but yeah
they're uh they're spending a boatload
of money on it
i'm in i'm i lo look i got hbo max
so i'm already in man you ain't got to
sell me i'm pre-sold
all my my only question mark
when how much
where well i guess we know where why we
know why
[Music]
[Laughter]
so we're answering most of this question
yes really just when and
how much well we know how much four
hours worth of it so when
right and how much free for you because
you're already paid because i already
pay for it which i don't yeah it's not
free but
so when when are they saying uh i think
it's 2021 woohoo
something to live for um same time
they'll be doing that
uh uh peacemaker series right
um yes yeah that's currently like james
gunn is writing those now
and i think production is going to start
as soon as you can kind of
produce stuff and now they have time
because suicide squad's not out until
next year
um yeah
damn you covered uh you saw the artwork
from uh empire yeah james gunn put it on
his instagram everybody have it or no
put it on the instagram do we not have
that artwork
probably best that we don't because
every time we [ __ ] show something
we get pulled off of [ __ ] youtube
anyone ever figure out what that was all
about
um apparently what happened jc why did
we get yanked down on that one
last time so i thought if we muted it
we'd be okay
still no but they have some image
recognition
and cbs viacom i guess just doesn't want
anybody
sharing the stand stuff except for
them because they knocked us yeah we
were
that that worked for quibby the idea of
no screenshots
quimby will live forever
um well fair enough i guess we can't
look at the
cover of empire if you're if you're
watching us on the internet
if you're watching this show chances are
you've already seen the artwork yes the
only faces you get to see now are these
this this is it this is a suicide squad
right here um
if you haven't seen it yet go look at
there are two covers one that's like the
newsstand cover
right and then a cover for subscribers
the news tank cover is like the cr you
know the
the cast all mean face and the
uh the subscriber cover is the cast with
james gunn and they're all smiling and
stuff but you get your first look at
king shark it's a it's the best
ridiculous image ever
it's like there's a shark just standing
there in jeans
not nearly as realistic looking as the
one from
cw like they went out on the cw one this
one looks like they're like look it's a
it's funny we're not gonna we're not
gonna make them look [ __ ] crazy it's
a shark dude real it's again it's a
shark man walking around
it's like one step shy of like sharknado
rat catcher it's cool i didn't know that
she would have like
rats to play with and stuff vermin on
the cover
the whole thing [ __ ] looks great
everybody wins
so so yeah there's going to be a lot of
[ __ ] in the snyder cut that nobody knew
was going to be in the snyder cut
um and yeah it's a just full-on brand
new thing
can't wait power to him um
i'll be texting joe to be like what do
you know
tell me things jeff yeah tell me some
[ __ ] he's like why don't you ask
batman and i'm like i only asked him for
one favor a decade and i've already used
mine
so and then some
tim burton what a genius see dumbo
i i never actually did see [ __ ]
pretty weird and wonderful
yeah yeah i mean you know everyone's
[ __ ] on it but it's [ __ ] all it did was
bite the hand
like it was an anti-disney disney movie
it was kind of crazy
um but yeah tim burton timbo himself
timbo himself is coming to television
oh my god that's it cinema's dead if
even tim burton's come to tv
yeah [ __ ] you i'm done
come on in tim the water's fine
and he's doing the most he's like you
don't have a tv show i'm like you're
right
he's doing the most perfectly tim burton
thing ever the adams family
oh no no no
[Music]
they have two cartoon movies don't they
aren't they doing a sequel to the
cartoon
yeah we're about to be flooded with
adams you can't [ __ ] kill this adam's
family it's like the hello kitty of
creepy families man it just
it'll always be around so in the
remember when we were kids you were
either a [ __ ] adams family person or
a monsters person
yes guess who won that war i mean okay
[ __ ] charles adams i actually don't
remember that
pop cultural feud that was just in my
house
it was
star trek monsters
adam's family that was when i he really
wanted to divide a culture
seriously bring it down to it hasty
white people do you like mo
monster white people in suburbia show
which one was your jam
and there's a dog shout out i honestly
like
as a child i think i liked the monsters
more
just because and i believe me i wasn't a
big monsters fan but
they had you know the [ __ ] dragon
under the stairs that was kind of badass
adam's family was like you know i i
don't know i
i didn't i like the movie better than
barry barry sonifeld flicks
yeah i was i was never an adams family
kid growing up
but i respect for it but just it wasn't
my taste when it went on i was like oh
couldn't this have been a cartoon
and then when they did it as a cartoon i
was like oh man couldn't they do this
live action
like i always want what i don't have
then i saw the original comic strip one
day by charles adams and was like oh
this is great but yeah i was here for
raul julia
and uh he was amazing uh that
incarnation of it
is what made it work for me in any way
yeah
and so like yeah all right i'm down to
see tim burton apparently he's
negotiating to executive produce and
maybe direct all of the episodes
which [ __ ] yeah give me that
um and if you've ever seen dart his dark
shadows you know that's a
[ __ ] that's gonna be great um alfred
goff
and miles milar are these gotham
aren't they the cats of the smallville
they have smallville they're into the
badlands
and they are the head writers in the
show and show runners and we'll
executive produce along with
tim burton right on there uh there's no
network as of now but the package has
multiple buyers bidding for it including
netflix
which sources say is at the top of the
list of landing the project
have you guys seen the pictures on the
internet of the in
color adams family living room no
it's it's painted the walls and the
floor are
are pink because it was always in black
and white i guess the pink
gave it the color they wanted in black
and white that's crazy if you google
it i'll look it up i remember seeing uh
like an alfred hitchcock documentary and
they were talking about how like
half of the [ __ ] you see in black and
white movies are the craziest colors
because each of those make a different
gray and so if you actually saw it in
color we'll look like a madman's mind
but no this this is exactly how i want
the values
um i made a black and white movie once
yeah was it all like do we have purple
walls and thanks guys she should have
seen that [ __ ] in real life actually
yeah the quick stuff is ugly as [ __ ] in
real life like
the color pattern when people walk in
they're like what the [ __ ] so
i i guess i guess that's true
um so yeah that's that is coming at some
point clearly clearly and i think it's
from the perspective of wednesday adams
oh viewpoint character there you go that
makes sense
can you get could you get christina
rishi to come in and play
morticia adams if you do a weird
if it were me that's exactly what i'd be
doing you'd be getting at least
associate producer credit for that
idea um yeah that'd be a great [ __ ]
idea she could totally pull it off man
absolutely um all right i'm on i'm on
board i got netflix so i'm watching that
um so you know we have talked in the
past about battlestar galactica i have
feelings
about battlestar we all do but you did a
whole podcast i did a whole podcast on
it so my feelings
many of them are public record um
and i i at one point even talked about
the fact that when uh
when the peacock had decided they wanted
to reboot battlestar galactica
and they asked sam s mail to oversee
that process the guy from mr robot the
mr
robot guy um i went in and i pitched on
that and i was like i would
i'll put my hat in the ring i would love
to try and make a battle struggle
activated it would be fun
um they didn't take my take i don't know
what take they're taking
but it's happening as a tv show i think
more inspired by the 2004 reboot than
the 1970s tv show
okay now universal
pictures has test simon kinberg
he of the x-men films um to
write and produce a new battlestar
galactica movie
they're doing two separate versions so a
movie version and a tv version with two
different cats two different universes
um
it seems to be that concept's not
[ __ ] strong enough to sustain
two incarnations at the same time no
um this ain't [ __ ] cw where you could
do the flash
and then have another flash in the
movies and people like oh okay
like this is a dumb idea you know and
also
battlestar galactica truth sponsored by
bud light
seltzer a rare opinion
from kev smith generally i'm very up and
positive about ship but
i'm gonna tell you right now this is
goofy in seltzer veritas
yeah this is a dumb idea don't do this
pick one you know pick a lane [ __ ]
yeah and also battle star
doesn't feel like a movie no it feels
like it's an episodic
it's an ongoing thing like are they
going to get to earth here's the [ __ ]
that happens in the way
they're like oh i got three movies to
get to earth it's like yeah [ __ ] you
do it for five years on television
better warmer
um silly silly silly silly
quite um it is not a case where i'm like
you know what i'll take all the battle
star i can get
just don't waste your time man like
[ __ ]
put all your eggs in one basket [ __ ]
the tv show
and go create a new movie franchise set
in space and [ __ ] just
steal the principles and change the
names you'll be fine
i mean you know like battlestar
galactica do yeah or like
spaceship in space ooh
just call it spaceship [ __ ] every
child in america will want to see it
children love spaceships they really do
call it spaceships and dinosaurs [ __ ]
you're giving away gold no never mind
spaceships and dinosaurs the chat uh the
chat's calling out what if the movie
is the 70s battle star with the old
cylons
and the tv show is another reboot of the
new battle star
so they could kind of exist in a weird
multiverse
and they're tonally very different uh
then i say to chat
this is what i have to say oh boy lean
in let me tell you
tell you something chat um i say chat's
far more creative than me and you should
come to hollywood
because [ __ ] i didn't think of that
that's a good idea it's a good ass idea
man
what are the chances that's going to be
the case to like one of these you know
[ __ ] mr universal's like hey [ __ ]
fat man beyond
drunken idiot maybe one of these is
going to be set in the 70s universe that
glenn larson was responsible for
and the other one's going to be a
quasi-new one based on the ron moore
universe would you be happy then
and in which case i would be very happy
about that i i would not because i don't
ever need to see the glendale
like have you seen those recently
they're tough they're not good yeah
well we still didn't get our dagget well
well we got a boxy there yeah there's a
boxing i think he had a dog
he didn't have a dagget though we don't
see either of them for further than the
mini series because they're like yeah we
don't need that
um yeah i'm back to you know
you know what chat you had me half
convinced cause i had
almost two of these but now i'm back
with him now i'm seeing with my
own two eyes it's a bad idea mark's
right
yeah i feel like the nostalgia cut to
neither of us getting hired by universal
ever again right
the nostalgia people have for battle
star is not for the 70s show
um it's for the 2004 show and you're
already doing an update of the 2004 show
so nostalgia as a re as a resource
only goes but so far you can't double
dip in the nostalgia man
no that can't do it you can't do it
the man said moving on moving on
hey willow's back speaking of nostalgia
this [ __ ] guy
um yeah god bless him uh ron howard been
talking about this for a red hot
uh hinting that this could be a
possibility
i'm happy uh for all involved but you
know
number one where's matt martign
i'm sure they will cast america
what a new one is it a prequel is it a
sequel
it's a sequel warwick davis is back as
back or but as a
as a sequel yeah so then get val kilmer
in that [ __ ] man
you need some mad martign in there
otherwise it ain't willow well i guess
it is willow if you got willow
um thoughts you happy about it listen i
was not a willow kid growing up
who was lots of people were what did i
hear you andrew
you liked it about jc you're a big uh
lucasfilm guy did you
did it extend even to the world of
willow i think i've seen it once
i'm i've i've not been crazy about
willow i'll probably watch it because i
like warwick davis
yeah i'm not i don't love it
um look you know it's disney they could
do what they want but
is anybody gonna sign up going like you
know i've been holding out
i hear this mandalorian's good but i
ain't buying that disney service and
then somebody's like
there's gonna be a willow series do you
think there's a single person in this
world that's like
now you have my money like willow's like
you know
an awesome get along with everything
else where you're like oh [ __ ] they did
willow
i might watch that one day and then you
never get to it but like i don't know
that that's a driver
it might not be a driver it might just
be a retainer
do tell in that you know there
might all the marvel stuff is your
driver mandalorian
is your driver like that's the stuff
that will actually get you to say oh
[ __ ] i wasn't going to do it
damn falcon and winter soldier down you
know
one division i'm here for it but then
you're like oh look at the rest of this
other [ __ ] that's on [ __ ] disney plus
that's cool
i'll hang out for a bit and so maybe
willow is one of those
that's cool i'll hang out for a bit
rather than oh you're gonna get my 11.99
a month [ __ ] and you're not
don't even try and give it back to me
because i'm here for the duration
so you know maybe it's that you know how
every streamer was doing this weird like
white noise television arms race we're
like we gotta have a friends
we gotta have a frasier we gotta have a
parks and rec we gotta have cheers like
we gotta have this deep bench
of kind of just stuff you can leave on
and forget that you were watching
not that willow's gonna be that but
there's there's the high and the low
of what the streamers look for i um i
mean good for them
happy for all involved they're all
getting to go back and
ron howard's involved right must be a
real kick for him to be like
we're revisiting this [ __ ] yeah decades
ago
um john chu crazy rich asians directors
directing the pilot and second producing
uh jonathan kasdan and wendy miracle are
the show running
shoes on harrow yeah and and he was uh
he was the solo solo kid right indeed
so like they got some good people you
know behind it who know how to make
television and tell stories
i support it but i like i won't get
around to it when it happens
very very soon unless somebody's like oh
my god you gotta watch it yeah willow's
a mind [ __ ]
forget everything you knew about willow
um but yeah it seems
pricey that ain't cheap man you ain't
pulling off willow for buck oh five
even if you got to break out those giant
screens the mandalorian screens like
oh you know they're breaking out the
screen it's gonna be expensive i
don't even you know
go get em i just if i was in charge i'd
be like you sure there ain't one more
marvel series we can do
like oh we got plenty of marvel series
yeah what about you know
she-hulk ready no but willow is like
willow huh
all right go ahead and bring it in for
like you know buckle five would you
bring it on budget i will
that's my ron howard i will well done
thanks
all right willow's coming you can't stop
it willow's coming you can't stop you
know what else you can't stop
you can't stop family you can't stop
hashtag family i as a guy who's never
watched these movies even i know that
hashtag family means the fast
and the faster the fast the fasten of
yours but apparently
you know what can stop dom toretto time
get out of here there are time it comes
for us all my lord
even for kings it comes indeed they are
pulling the fast and furious franchise
into the garage
why are they just tired of printing
money
like we've printed all the money we can
we're finished with our money heist
aka la casa del papel we've got all the
money there is to have and stuff why
would you stop making these like
as long as they make cars make one of
these movies just replace the [ __ ]
hashtag family with hashtag newer
fresher faced family
well i think they will um but it's gonna
be right they'll wind this up and be
like
hey man we'll let them drive off in nine
different directions this time
yeah and then they'll wait two years and
then they'll be like look at these
kids look at these cars it's happening
again
yeah the the ninth of the fast and
furious films uh were supposed to come
out this year won't be out until
memorial day 2021 but now they've
announced that the franchise will come
to a conclusion after the 10th and 11th
films
um so yeah we're not done done oh my god
there's not even
an even 10 they're like let's take it to
let's push this to 11.
everything goes to 11 baby well
there it is something to look forward to
if you're into car movies yeah
so you know spin-off movies based on it
are absolutely gonna happen you've
already got
hobbs and shaw fast and furious presents
hobbs and shaw um
there's a thousand characters in this
universe all of which could probably
hold down some version of a movie
um they're never going to not want to
make money on this but i think the
mainline
narrative of dominic toretto and letty
and whoever else is still standing um
will come to a conclusion
they also have a character named letty
yeah like
i love craft country so funny because
i'm like i'm completely
ignorant of fast and furious culture
which has been going on for a decade
indeed so when i watch lovecraft country
i'm like letty what a great original use
of a name
and a lot of other people are just like
you know oh where's dom
so weird pop culture's passing me by
kids you said my finger on the pulse now
my fingers straight up my ass
but it's it's a well shorn ass thank you
thanks the good folks
manscaped
if you want to jam your finger up your
ass but you don't want to get tied
around those
nasty rectal pubes manscaped that's
too long of a tag line i think it got a
little expensive i like the other one
yeah
sometimes we're saving that for late
night cells
ah fat man after dark
i believe that's the [ __ ] my wife's
biography title
batman after the dark the jennifer
schwab story uh yo
batman's broke
what in the comic books they made him no
longer a billionaire
in the in batman number 101 the latest
issue the twice a monthly comic book
written by james tyne in the fourth and
drawn by gila march
the iconic dc hero is forced to come to
terms with the state of gotham city in
the wake of the joker war storyline
which uh batman's fortune bruce wayne's
fortune was stolen by the joker and then
stolen again by catwoman
but not returned to wayne it was then
placed in the trust of lucious fox
and the government is paying attention
and they're like yeah man you
give your car breaks you got to fix it
man like you don't get tumblers and [ __ ]
anymore your greatest asset
which had been your bank account is now
not yours anymore
and so how does a batman without all of
that [ __ ]
operate how do you feel about that
i mean didn't they do that in dark
knight rises they took away all his
money it was poor at the end and [ __ ]
remember they bankrupted him she took
over the board or whatever the [ __ ] and
i thought at one point remember they
have sex after he loses all the money
and then she could have knifed him right
there and saved us all a [ __ ] lot of
trouble but instead they just had sex
and then later on in the third act she
was like i'm the bad guy
don't you remember remember berries
um yeah i feel like i've seen this
before i've seen him lose his money
before
i feel like he not in the comics though
to be fair yeah
i think it was always like a somebody
did a bad thing to his money
but he was smart and he bought it up we
bought up all the stock and nobody saw
him doing it
right now he once again is the major
chairman and
ceo this is going to be fun then for a
while he's got to figure out how to do
batman low budge
right low budge batman just call the
book that
yeah which is otherwise like just dude
who punches people
it's true low budge batman is a dude
that just races around the city with a
bat in his hand [ __ ] hitting
chain snatchers and muggers and stuff he
used to call him crazy bruce
i didn't call him a batman
that's deep cuts i'm glad you stand by
me my friend
or lean on me uh yes i stand in
delivered bench yes that's
it um all right well
[ __ ] good for everybody on that
what's next indeed
smokey in the bandit what is coming to
your television screens
um the iconic uh franchise from the
70s and maybe a little bit of the 80s as
well
indeed why
why would you do this uh without burt
reynolds
uh no you can't have birmingham cannot
have bert reynolds no
you don't without jerry reid no jerry
reid
also did without sally field um
you could have her pop in you need her
at least in the pilot
um without uh jackie gleason
indeed yeah no smoking they've been
doing without him for a while
no nobody what is it tv show where tv
show
um david gordon green is uh is gonna
sort of oversee it along with seth
macfarlane
um let's see blah blah blah blah blah
blah
where's this going comes out of uh
seth macfarlane's company's deal with
ucp
um the universal uh content production
company and so that means it might end
up on the peacock it means they might
you know sort of
bring it to market and see if they can
sell it elsewhere but
yeah i thought the smokey and the banded
tv series was called the dukes of hazard
technically one inspired the other um
very much so
but you know i think there's there's a
way to do i mean part of the the the
issues with smoking the bandit
which might seem you know not entirely
insurmountable but
it's about the south it's about the deep
south it's about the culture of
bootlegging it's about
um you know the south will rise again
is a joke that gets tossed off i think
in more than one of those movies
um so figuring out how to you know
embrace
the things about the south that that are
still worth championing while also
sidestepping the things that in the last
couple of years we've all come to
realize are maybe not
worth holding on to the good thing is
that yeah david gordon green
is doing it and danny mcbride is one of
the producers as well
and if there's a person who's figured
out how to navigate that
love for the south while being able to
be honest about the south
and still finding what's funny about it
dana mcbride is that guy
so i am cautiously optimistic um
you are east bounding down with it yes i
am we're gonna do what they say it can't
be done
we got a long way to go in a short time
to get there i'm eastbound just watch
old band
and run there's more lyrics that i don't
know though
that's all you need that tells a story
right there
they're eastbound and down kids they're
loaded up and trucking
yeah the wheels are rolling that's uh i
love the
movie from my childhood i do
um i have warm memories of seeing that
with my family when burt reynolds was
the number one box office star in
america and
um all of it all the warm memories of
childhood
yeah i mean i love that movie even
though i know that
some of that movie's not for me um
you know there's there's some there's
some unfortunate race [ __ ]
is it really i haven't seen in a long
time i honestly haven't seen that movie
in over 30 years
yeah i mean and you know you gotta it's
one of those movies
that uh that i have to squint at a
little bit he's like
yeah i know he was made in 75. is it
beaufort t
justice is he the there's a lot of it
problematic
yeah they made you a captain
really yeah whoa jesus
he's down and not down with that at all
no not down with the opp it turns out
um but yeah so i'm i'm curious
cautiously optimistic but i do have a
love built deep in my soul
for cars jumping over [ __ ] i guess
that's
like that's uh sorry man two of those
and i'm [ __ ] like ready to go to
sleep i guess that's the
also the draws like in a world where
fast and furious is [ __ ] huge
then the original let's look at cars do
weird
[ __ ] is smoking the bandit so
that makes sense i'm out of touch like
like [ __ ] uh hauling oats once sang
i'm out of touch and the fact that i had
to use a hall of notes reference to
say the amount of touch shows you how
out of touch that i am
um but you're not everyone's building an
empire and [ __ ] making [ __ ] out of
old [ __ ] oh
you know what we got masters of the
universe [ __ ] all those people we're
doing the same thing
just like tim burton we got our own
adams family yes
that thing you loved as a kid we're
doing it too and we're taking out all
the awkward race [ __ ] i was getting
ready to get judgey about like why don't
you let the pass be the past
but our mo tube is pretty [ __ ]
amazing
you know what i've got waiting for me
when i get home episode
10. wow the animatics you got to come
over and watch them all
i will um i've i've done that with uh
dia came over and watched tim came over
and watched them all from
beginning to end it's so [ __ ] good
it's so good you know what based on that
maybe
smoking the bandit will be [ __ ]
brilliant because you never can tell
somebody told me like one of your
favorite things that you're gonna that
you've ever worked on is gonna be
this [ __ ] he-man cartoon if they told
me that at the beginning i feel like
you're out of your mind but now i'm like
i believe it
some legacy [ __ ] i might retire after
this and be like
and just step away uh-oh they're coming
for you here they are the retirement
police they're like coming
you said it [ __ ] back to jersey with
you
um last story of the night um
of all of the stephen king movies that
have been ever been made
the shining is that your favorite the
shining
uh incorrect answer sir [ __ ] um
which do you think is the most ripe for
a remake
[Music]
the most ripe for a remake yes of all
the stephen king movies
[Music]
you have to walk down a blockbuster and
like you know what i'm gonna do
one of these
well in a world where you know we're
just talking about ooh [ __ ] car
movies and car culture christine is
probably ripe for the remaking
there's a car at the center of it you
could probably do some [ __ ] you could
let it jump out a building or fast and
furious that [ __ ] for a scene or two i'm
sure that'd be modern
um let's see salem's lot
feels kind of timeless you could always
do that i think they're working on one
version of that
um you know
people love animals so cujo is kind of
time unless you do that any old time
the stand makes sense because of captain
trips
where on that list for you is maximum
overdrive
i left it off because i was like nobody
would be stupid enough to remake maximum
overdrive
you know who wants to who joe hill
stephen king's son you know what i'm
gonna stop drinking these
cause they're getting real mouthy about
like you know what it
can't be done it's impossible and then
you tell me his son wants to do it and
i'm like
i'll watch that that's fantastic oh my
god i love the narrative
behind the narrative of like the kid
going like all right let me see if we
can get this right
mm-hmm like he was as long as they keep
the [ __ ] green goblin truck i don't
give a [ __ ]
you have to um but yeah he was on um joe
hill did an episode of mick
garris's um post-mortem podcast
who's made a physique everybody have a
podcast now
you know it's all your fault man
mcgarris yeah he's a horror meister he's
a horror meister who made his share of
stephen king works he made the
he made the tv stand the one with uh
rebecca de mourney
and i think he also stephen webber i
think he also did the tv shining
if i'm correct oh that's what i meant
the tv shining i didn't
i don't think i don't know if he did the
stand he did do the stand i know he did
the shining yeah
he did them both he did the stand as
well he did this down as well m-o-o-n
that spells mcaris but he was on the
podcast and and mick had asked him
you know have you ever thought about
directing yeah and he said you know
i would only want to jump into directing
if i had a chance to do the reboot of
maximum overdrive
that's funny and you know not for
nothing like maximum overdrive
is a notoriously bad movie and it is but
the idea behind that
isn't like totally insane it's a little
bit battlestar galactica when you think
about it
which is you know bsg is about you know
sentient ai eventually turning against
mankind
and so is maximum overdrive like there's
some comet strike
and you know suddenly all of the world's
machines become hyper intelligent and
want to kill
all of the people this
works it works like yeah maybe the
other one is daffy but
you know tried to make plants scary you
know
machines will always be scarier than
plants you guys
i think it's the trees and didn't he
also like stephen
king king write the cell phone movie
what's that [ __ ] called
uh signal no
cell no cellular no no
i thought i don't even think it has like
a cell thing in the title but it's the
you know it's a book about murder like
the phones kill people right
yeah i know michael crichton also called
cell
um but stephen king also did one but
yeah
um well i look forward to seeing joe
hill's version of his dad's maximum
overdrive and that is both
that is the only way that i would like
to see it agree co-sign
that's all the news we got that's all
the news we got brother give it up for
mark he brought you some [ __ ] news
ladies and gentlemen
now we open up the evening to you
the home viewer i got like a swallow
left of this
so that means there's a little more
truth coming your way so
ask some questions jc there he's going
to pick him out of the chat how's the
chat been tonight jc
uh chad's good uh stephen king wrote a
book called
sell sell i guess you were right i was
fighting mark i was i was uh
king explaining to mark that that was
not the case um we had some good uh we
had some other good comments mr mad
crack said as long as fast and the
furious 10 is called
fast 10 your seat belts ooh
nice oh [ __ ] that's clever see that's
why i got to get out of this game
everyone's way more clever than me
when i made clerks i felt clever but now
i feel like an old man
and i'm like i didn't think it took me a
few seconds to put that together i'm
like
past ten years oh my god that's
brilliant well once once we start the
podcast
i feel like you'll be back up and
running on your fast and furious
you'll be able to punt like a madman
fair enough good
thanks for the thing i got you
uh chris housenik uh thought that batman
must have been a primary investor in
quibby
so i thought that was pretty good and
then we had a lot of kind i would say
uh seem more appropriate that the flash
was uh
an investor in quibby because it came
and went
indeed came and went
and john holmes was investing
no it wasn't john holmes who invested
quite because he was long
strong out of the gate didn't last very
long quibby short
quick bite we uh we also had a lot of
comments about your robe being a jedi
robe
oh which i thought was very nice i think
they're absolutely right
and then the kindest description of a
robe ever thank you yes
most people would be like it seems like
a kind of you gave up bro but
the people in the chat are like no no no
that's a jedi robe
yes he's one with the force and the
forces one with me yeah he's forcing his
[ __ ] home
fashion on us uh and then will f in the
chat
said uh he thought you were dressed like
the guys
in the future from demolition man so you
were doing a demolition man cosplay i am
cosplaying as [ __ ]
wow as uh simon says it was
that was the movie that where he was
like simon phoenix simon phoenix
yes simon says [ __ ]
um all right well good to know and good
to know that people aren't fighting in
the chat
or being shitty right they got your guys
back yes
i look forward to uh to manscape coming
out with the three shells
yeah hell yeah uh okay
question question we have uh the first
question is from brad latem
hey brad um he wanted to know
if you guys had a genie and you could
make three wishes what would those
wishes be
jesus oh just in general well the number
three wish of course
is three more wishes yes and then that
goes on a lifetime so really it's only
two wishes
um
did you know that in the traditional
myth there is no lamp the lamp was an
addition by like a french translator to
make it a little bit more exotic
what was it then what did the genie live
in um the genie wasn't in prison that
way like you just stumble upon a dude
and like you could ask him questions if
you knew he was a genie
but the entire like rubbing of a lamp
and the prison
version of it they added that later on
not part of the original lore gotta tell
you captures the imagination
what do you mean he lives in a lamp it's
not a bed and it's how
young kids first learn what a lamp an
oil lamp is
right and slavery and what
and what now hold on um
yes i guess you're right um let me see
my two wishes then
you know
i'm sure some would be tempted to like
go back and undo
2016 but like you know maybe just
make sure that going forward
everything's good
instead of wishing backwards wishing
forward
um
uh you know i was always very impressed
by uh when neil gaiman took over
miracle man the comic at one point he
had miracle man like and the miracle man
family
took over the world they're like look
you guys can't be trusted with the world
so we're gonna be in charge for a while
until
you know you got we're convinced you
won't hurt each other anymore
and they said one of the first things
they're doing was like we're
you know as of august 12th we're
eradicating all the money in the world
and you know goods and services will be
traded
bartered for other goods and services
crops what have you
but there'll be no more currency no more
financial currency
um you know it seemed like that might be
good wish great equalizer i know you
know i'm sure
somebody out there would be like you
idiot what about x y and z
but yeah but then again that also sounds
like a real monkey's paw kind of thing
where i'm like
i wish there was no more money and it's
like and then suddenly
[ __ ] you know dinosaurs walked the
earth or some sort of [ __ ]
i don't know man you know you know um
racial equality [ __ ] justice
[ __ ] i'd like the federation please
the federation of planets well they're
like first off find some planets
um you know eternal life
really what's that yeah locked in at the
age of my choice though
not so like i'm [ __ ] a thousand and i
look at
i want to be a thousand but i want to
look like this dorian gray style
okay yeah but i can i can you know i
know it's like
you have to watch everyone you love die
but like
i i have watched a lot of people i love
die
so you know i think i can handle like
glad that ain't gonna happen to me you
know
[Laughter]
who dodged a bullet there jesus that
looks painful
i look forward to your thanksgiving
guess what i'd like to give the blessing
they're like oh here we go
son of a [ __ ] he wants to live forever
he hopes we could watch us all die
same prayer i'm thankful that i'm going
to live forever
just pass the mashed potatoes would you
uncle cab [ __ ]
you're so hateful you ah i guess it's
it is a very big question um
i think the the the miracle man slash
united federation of planets idea which
is very much about
you know money doesn't exist you know
people get to live
for the betterment of themselves and
pursuing
sort of loftier goals and the amassing
of money and wealth and
property and all that stuff did they do
that on star trek that's that's
essentially the core of the foundation i
mean the federation they said that in
like one of the episodes like we don't
have money
yeah like nobody's got any money you got
any money like no jim
tim you got any money [ __ ] no i got no
money yeah we don't have any pockets
where we gonna put the money we have no
pockets
we got rid of money we covered our
pockets we're [ __ ] in the future
yeah that was the original title of the
show gene roddenberry's [ __ ] in the
future
but then he changes to star trek because
you know no pockets no pockets
pc culture but yeah that's that's
sort of the way the federation works is
that so neil gaiman stole it from star
trek
entirely possible my god i thought that
was like the most original thing i'd
ever read i was like that'd be [ __ ]
wicked but they did it in star trek
like 30 years earlier no it all comes
around neil
um i feel like i would like a cure to
all diseases
um no more maladies no more maladies i
feel like
you know especially any disease that
befalls
children um could do without that which
would also get rid of big pharma which
is probably a very very good thing
um probably make medicine a little bit
smaller also a very good thing
um i feel like so i got federation i got
no more childhood diseases
and i want mutants
i just want i just want the like the the
look on scallop which is lips
i'm gonna use one of my wishes for a
[ __ ] paper towel to clean up this
jizz
filled my pants i can't believe i was on
this show in this bar
nonetheless and skipped the obvious we
could do the reverse
wanda maximoff and just be like mutants
oh [ __ ] do you give yourself a power
is everyone a mutant or just some um i
feel like just some because again if
everybody's a mutant then it's not that
good and nobody's mutant then nobody's
everybody's special no one is um but do
you get a power
um i suppose i mean i suppose given that
i am now the don't be coy you're like
wow i i suppose i could have one myself
you know if if i'm given things then i
might as well give to me
um yeah i give myself a [ __ ] power
what is it ah
you know i always i love storm's powers
to control the weather control the
weather because a cool lightning [ __ ]
b rain c you also get to fly
and it's the showiest power like when
you're angry the world
kind of changes very true you know i uh
i hate going outside so that ain't for
me
um what are good indoor powers you know
the power to like [ __ ] change the
channel without using the remote that's
[ __ ] the force
you just i just want like
mild grade telekinesis i don't want a
lot i just want to be able to like
change the world
of the x-men of the classic lineup of
the x-men
yes i wouldn't want this [ __ ]
my [ __ ] eye lasers are not that
useful oh i thought you were going like
a
professor x oh i would love that because
they both just like like fingers to the
two
my mutants um yeah i wouldn't want the
[ __ ] optic
ruby quartz optic blast yeah that seems
a shitty power
jean's power is a little has always been
kind of ill-defined but she's
psychic super psychic she's super yes
she's got telekinesis
and telekinesis and pyro she's got all
the kinesis
read mine she's very kinetic super
kinetic uh
beast nobody wants that nope unless
you're gonna get that man kind of
badass but like you know you got a
kryptonite right away
yeah if you know how to beat you yeah
they know how to beat you right away
like
i'm ice man i'm here to when they pull
out the flame thrower and you're done
um plus nobody wants to see the [ __ ]
those icy highways you leave behind
and [ __ ] those fall apart fall on
people's heads
really you're just a public hazard and
then who was the remaining
ex-angel angel
i would like the power to fly but i
don't want the cumbersome wings in the
process
um and then of course professor x i'm
gonna go with jean grey
i want jeans powers of the original
lineup man okay
yeah i mean i feel like gene gene is one
of the few and professor x who don't
have the downside of their powers you
know like
scott has concussive blasts but also
gonna wear those [ __ ] shitty glasses
right you know gene didn't have to
really pay any price
no aside from you know she's a girl
yeah she's like oh shucks you mean i'm
now the prettiest
right and because i'm a girl i don't
know how to control my power
because again you know old white noise i
would rather be jean over professor x
because
he's like you got to if you're in charge
of a school you got to do the budgets
and [ __ ] like that
paperwork and that seems really boring
you're gene you're out in the field
you're saving scott
logan's trying to [ __ ] you as well it's
the life of adventure
romance professor x is like i got to
deal with school lunches
yeah he's just like they're trying to
defund our school
like i know i'm rich but i like i'll
take any free money
that's how you stay rich he's just like
writing grants
he's just getting drunk and talking to
the kids to me my mutants
let me tell you something [ __ ] the
government yeah let me tell you about
bias and testing
um all right so that's a pretty good
answer i think we did ours that went
pretty far
well done yeah nice job all right next
up
all right uh this is from glassmaker
540.
bring it maker kind of an odd one but
it's kind of fun
he wants to know or they want to know
would you rather have
a sandwich named after you at a famous
deli
or walk or a walk-on part in your
favorite tv show and
if it's the sandwich what's the sandwich
what's on it
and if it's the part or if it's if you
like the walk-on part what's the part
and what's the show
okay [ __ ] i like this yeah nice one
yeah i got option specific
very specific like what are your three
wishes oh then he wishes
it's like the the funnest mad libs it
just has to fill in a couple blanks
um all right sandwich i would choose the
tv show over the sandwich because
[ __ ] sandwich like only people
that go to the restaurant would ever
know
the tv show i don't care if it's my
favorite i'm picking the one that's the
most
watched because then that's good for my
brand if i'm on it and they're like oh
[ __ ] he's relevant
so if kevin smith on a csi why yes it
is you think i'm picking you think i'm
picking csi like what is the most
popular show
it's csi [ __ ] you want like
friends or big bang theory or seinfeld
get that resilient they're all cancelled
yeah but the residuals so wait now i
gotta go back in time to do this [ __ ] as
well
wow let's see this is us
that ain't my favorite show oh you're
looking for the big shows
you're a good point yeah we can't play
favorites we're just looking for
yeah [ __ ] sheer numbers here totally
like you can be a walking
debate i want to go on one of the
debates and just stand between the guys
and be like
i'll be like the fly the fly got a lot
of press
is that kevin smith yeah what's his head
silent bob at the debate
he was nodding a lot um let me see
first sandwich uh i thought you got to
pick i don't think it's either or
you can't do both fair enough i mean
good i mean it's you all right tv show
what is my favorite tv show or
what is one that would travel like a
long way
uh oh all right i got one saturday night
live
nice uh i want to play
um a uh commentator
uh well i want to be on the whole
episode right it's a walk-on role though
it's not like you're the star
all right then i want to be uh i want to
be a weekend update
commentator because that's the chance it
could grow into something more if i was
really funny if i kill
they maybe they invite me back then i
got a job and maybe i'm going somewhere
and show business
finally see i would like to see you as
one of the
the panelists on what's up with that
what's up with that what's up with that
what's up i said what's up
with that
if you're gonna go to scum and villainy
you better bring a quarter to flip at
the bartender
after you cut off the guy's arm
i got to speculate um
that's me i'm going i'm going it's snl
but if it's sandwich a beyond burger or
a falafel sandwich
or peanut butter and jelly if they just
named a peanut butter and jelly sandwich
how about that
just worldwide they renamed the peanut
butter and jelly sandwich the kev smith
just tomorrow everybody's like everybody
smith
everybody agreed to it and [ __ ] that'd
be nice if i
die work on that
you know what i'm saying if you got more
lives just be like this is kooky but he
always wanted the peanut butter and
jelly sandwich renamed after him
it might work yeah get that trending
yeah what was the last conversation you
had with kev
well here's the thing he wanted to force
himself into everyone's foods
yes it wasn't enough that he forced
himself into their [ __ ] pop culture
he wanted to invade their favorite foods
as well you really wanted to be in
children's mouths
so he said i want to be named i want the
peanut butter jelly to not be the kevin
smith
uh i go sandwich 100 what yes
sandwich over [ __ ] tv show you could
be on star trek but it's a walk-on roll
on star trek like [ __ ]
no [ __ ] sandwich because what
happened to you
star trek brought you to hollywood
dreams of star trek
i just remember going when i worked at
entertainment weekly
we were a block away from letterman yeah
on broadway
and so every like fourth or fifth day we
would end up at the hello deli
for lunch and seeing the people who got
sandwiches named after them was like
come on rupert like i'm in every [ __ ]
week man
why did i get a sandwich and he would
never give me a sandwich
what would it be it would be what would
you call the bernardin
uh yeah yeah totally what
pretty original much um you know what i
call it
i call it the fat man delight oh brandon
the fat man delight that means i get to
bank off your success a little bit
i like this sandwich uh i think it's
let's see chicken cutlet lettuce tomato
bacon
american cheese uh
mayo ketchup coleslaw
i'm with you on the ketchup and the mayo
and the chicken
rest of it i'd be leaving it off but i'm
happy that that chicken that's named
after us
why not call it a fat man bernardin
that's
insulting though it's a little bit yeah
yeah i feel like that wasn't my intent
like hold on now um [ __ ] man
you choose a sandwich i choose a
sandwich because people will be eating
that sandwich
for as long as that restaurant's around
they'll forget my walk-on on star trek
and and they will eat the sour to the
like warm happy thoughts
that's true as they are just or they'll
be like who was that who is the bernard
and they're like oh well let me tell you
he was a man who had one wish and he
wished for a sandwich to be named after
him
he said genie you can keep the other two
i just want a sound
he said no to television yes to a
sandwich
yes world peace no time travel
no that's a good question sandwich
that's a good question yielded some
honest
[ __ ] responses well done glass person
yes well done
very very glassy not very assy our final
question of the evening jc you did kind
of have a walk-on role
in one of your favorite shows i have
many times yeah
what were you thinking of the simpsons i
did absolutely i was that's why honestly
like this is going to sound so gosh and
i don't want to turn anybody off on a
saturday night but like
when they were like what are your wishes
i was like they all [ __ ] came true
like literally i mean you know now i've
i hope my i don't wish but i hope my kid
lives forever i hope i live forever but
like
my wishes that [ __ ] happened man so like
when somebody's like well if you had
three wishes i'd be like
i don't know clerk small rats chasing
him it already happened and [ __ ]
that's why sandwich
sandwich there's a [ __ ] good name for
a movie
sandwich you go into a deli it's like a
magical deli and [ __ ] run by
i don't know whoopi goldberg sandwich
and it takes you to your favorite moment
in your life you go back to that place
in your life where you're [ __ ] up and
you can correct [ __ ] right it's the
prustian delhi
yes um all right final question in the
evening all right last question is from
hank pena hank his 50th birthday is
coming up this thursday
and he says he's feeling the picard
quote fewer years ahead than behind
thing
and he'd like to know what non-work
bucket list items or hobbies
you and mark are keen on tackling
non-work this is going to show
how vacuous that i am but i don't really
have any
non-work dreams or hobbies there's
nothing outside of what i do for a
living
that i can think of that i'm like i've
always wanted to do that like
we're because we were watching uh money
heist
and it was set it's set in spain at the
beginning of our our relationship
uh jen went with me because i was going
to uh
valencia to receive uh they had a film
festival and i was getting like an award
and [ __ ]
and so as we were watching you know
money high she's like we've we've never
been back to
spain since like [ __ ] we first met
like
you know we should go back to spain i'm
like we should go anywhere if they would
ever open the borders again i don't know
if you've read the news but nobody's
nobody going she's like when this is all
over can you will you take me to spain
and i was like um yeah man because like
they love me there like we
wanna like citches and and [ __ ] uh
with red state and stuff like that
and i was like in the comic stuff i was
like i could totally hook up
a reason to go so my mind instantly
always goes
to work where i'm like oh i'll take you
to the place where you're talking about
going
but i'll take us there because i'll hook
up some work thing
so work is so much ingrained to me and
and
i use the term work loosely because it's
not work but my career
what i do and all that [ __ ] that kevin
smith nonsense i
i don't have anything separate of that
is that horrible to admit
i don't know that's for you and your
therapist to decide i don't have one of
those
i'm too self-involved why would i talk
to somebody else
talk to the audience um i don't i don't
yeah i don't i mean look this is gonna
sound shitty and stupid but
i always wanted to see where they make
the cereal
you know what dude they do it in battle
creek michigan that's where all the
cereals made go to [ __ ] battle creek
get yourself some of that sweet-ass
series i just want to see how it's done
i want to see how do you make a
cornflake
from the [ __ ] keg that's interesting
to me so i don't know maybe that
i guess but i never see a place like we
were watching again money heist
and at one point these [ __ ] are on
this like beautiful arc what how do you
say archipelago
archipelago what is it archipelago
archipelago like
it's which is a tiny island baby island
whatever [ __ ]
and they're on a raft floating in the
bluest [ __ ] water you ever saw
and my wife is like oh my god that looks
like a dream
and to me it looked like an absolute
nightmare nothing about it was appealing
to me and stuff
so i yeah i don't i don't have any
desires oddly enough
about you dallas
cowgirls all of them
[ __ ] cheerleaders man i just want to
be buried up to my night that's not true
i was like this is we're getting to the
hardest [ __ ] tonight um who drank the
bud seltzers me or you
yeah who drank the actual beer that is
feeling strong
real man's alcohol as they say look at
them crushing that can like dick dry for
some jaws
with all the strength of a middle-aged
professor
um it's a it's it's a travel thing
you know because i unlike you have not
you know been around the world
quite yet i've seen some [ __ ] i've been
i've been some places but
i've always wanted to take the kids on a
on a sort of like heritage vacation
oh nice you know like we are all you
know both my wife and i are both from
various islands right um my wife from
ireland and the uk
portland ireland and my
my family hails from haiti and barbados
and trinidad so
something it's fine it's wild you're all
island people all island people so like
taking the kids to this sort of like
let's go
to where you come from and what that
feels like what i think be
really really interesting but i don't
you know i don't want to jump out of a
plane
i think planes if it's perfectly good
i'm not jumping out of it
um i don't really like cruises so i
don't want to do that
you know like i'm not a beach person i'm
a city person
so but i there's plenty of cities i've
never been to and it would be nice to go
and
like see some of the world if there's a
reason for somebody to pay for me to do
that
even better um but if not just [ __ ]
go in and see some [ __ ]
um but yeah the doing of things is not
high on my bucket list but the being of
places
that is that is i don't have any doing
of things being of places
um living forever that's the one i'd
love to
try but it doesn't seem to work for
anybody and i'm not particularly smart
so i'm not going to figure it out
any more so than anyone else has but
yeah there's
you know i mean there's like more of
what i've done where i'm like oh
variations of the theme i would like to
do that again i would like to make
another movie i'd like to make another
tv show or whatever
but uh nothing that i'm like you know
one day
i'm gonna get there um i i just i kind
of
i i got very fortunate and i and i'm
also like
insanely into like kevin smith so
those are the things that every day i
get up and kind of go like what do i
want to do
there's no bucket list because i kind of
knock it off on a daily
basis does that make sense it sounds a
little gross i know but
um yeah so weird that's twice tonight
where i'm like the wish question
throws me also a question always throws
me when people go like did you have fun
my wife does that all the time
she's like like i'll come home from this
tonight and she'll be like do you have
fun
and i'll be like i mean like i wouldn't
say
fun but like a it was productive b it
was easy
c we had a good time and we laughed but
like
like when your entire existence is
predicated on like
i want to make pretend and [ __ ] like
that your whole [ __ ] life is fun
so there's not any one aspect that's
like more fun than the rest so when she
and it always stops me in my tracks i
should just be like
yeah it was fun but i can't lie to her
and [ __ ] so like
when she's like you know was it fun i'm
always like
well define fun you should be like all
right fine you had a good time go just
shut the [ __ ] up but yeah it's my
fun and meter is broken because
[ __ ] you know my career has been so
off the charts fun
uh my bucket list meter is broken and
stuff and
i'm not complaining these are all good
things and [ __ ] as far as i'm concerned
and it also has a lot to do with like
the heart attack when i almost died like
i cleared my decks where i was like well
i'm ready to [ __ ] go and i was legit
ready
not like i want to die but just like all
right this is it the guy said i'm
probably going to drop dead
i've done enough like this is [ __ ]
great and then
he saved me and now i'm just like living
on borrowed time and i'm like i better
keep [ __ ]
the balls up in the air like i'll be
honest with you at one point when they
were like you might die i was like
i could finally take a break yeah you
know
i don't have to think about making a
movie a podcast or any of that stuff
because once you turn
on the switch it's a lifetime of that
you know and you never i'm not one of
those people some
i took like three years off of making
movies once but i still did
everything else and stuff i could never
step away
because i know like even now like i'm
not as
in buried deep in the pop culture as i
used to
but i know if i stepped away for like
i'm going to take a year to myself
because i've always wanted to do
something
and let's be honest i guess the sad
thing is i've never wanted to do
anything that doesn't involve
or center around me is what i guess i'm
getting at and stuff
but the notion of taking a year off and
then trying to get back into the swing
of things and stuff like
[ __ ] moves too fast at this point man
like if you take your head out for a
little vacation
from two or three quibbys come and gone
yeah
so i'm i'm i'm it's fun for me to get up
every day and try to stay
in this business try to stay relevant
that to me
is fun because it's a challenge and
there's a fear of like what if i get it
wrong and what if i'm done at a certain
point
that's enough adventure for me
fair enough you uh travel
[Laughter]
um i'm gonna fly first class yeah there
you go go [ __ ]
beef it up a little bit would you [ __ ]
um
there it is i hope hopefully that answer
uh went down smoothly enough yeah i mean
it's you know i do a lot of speaking
uh so at a certain point like there
isn't really anything that i haven't
shared yet
you know what i'm saying like there's no
unplumbed depth so to speak
so like it's it's not like anyone's ever
gonna ask a question where i'm like
well here's something they'll never
they've never known about me
um you know but i think that is rather
revealing
at how like disinterested i am
in the world maybe i've just seen enough
of the world because my job wound up
taking me out there i don't know but
really the only thing i'm interested in
is keeping it going i can't believe i
kept it going this long
so now i'm just like can i keep it let
me see how long i can keep this [ __ ]
going man
now it's a bet yeah i cannot do it
longer totally
until i [ __ ] drop dead which
hopefully is later rather than sooner
for me for him for all of you indeed
that's our wish that's a hopeful way to
end the show you don't die yet
thank you for your questions uh thanks
for hanging out and [ __ ] listening
did you have a good time kids
did you have fun [ __ ] yeah you did were
you laying around in your robes
enjoying the show like i was i put on
actual [ __ ] pants today and he
actually got dressed i'm bottomless
under here you can't see under the bar
thank heavens and stuff
he is dying there's why you enjoyed the
show
mr manscaped himself manscaping mark
bernardin as we call him
uh here in the in the wrestling ring of
the scum and villainy cantina
thank you also uh to our hosts uh the
j square jc and jen owners of this here
barr scum and villainy and their future
progeny
who will inherit it when they've left
this place
that's all a kid is let's hang this
albatross around this kid's head
the inheritor of [ __ ] everything that
you want uh
give it up for andrew without whom
there'd be one shot it'd be like c-span
in this [ __ ]
so at least we get to switch around man
uh give it up for
the only audience we'll ever need deacon
he's hanging out over there man we do
all right tonight deacon
thumbs up he's so vocal it's crazy
that's why we have him here because he
livens the room up with his loudness in
his laughter
um and that's why we have you here
ladies and gentlemen thanks
for hanging out with us on a saturday
night we ain't doing this next week
because don't forget i'm heading to
chicago for uh
movies is opening october 30th i'll be
there october 30th for the grand opening
october
31st for halloween then me and jay are
doing jay and sam bob get old
at uh the uh mchenry outdoor theater
which deacon
an illinois native has informed me is in
the middle of nowhere
so you may get lost looking for us we
may all get lost together out there
doing a show ladies and gentlemen but
that's going to be on
november 1st then i come home on
november 2nd
and we're going to do a show that night
we are monday before election day
we're going to come in here and we're
going to do a get out the vote special
i mean you know let's let's i imagine by
that point everyone's already voted i
voted you vote already not yet
no what not yet yeah are you good to go
do it in person or something i'm going
to do in person
yeah because i i all that i'm hearing is
that like if it's possible to do it in
person
um it's it's more advantageous i think
for the
the counting of votes um because you
know of of the way
well you know you've all seen how it's
going to end up going down which is you
know lots of
democrats are voting early because they
don't want to expose themselves to the
covid so it's lots of mail-in voting
lots of you know ballot drop boxing
um while lots of republicans are going
to vote day of
because they apparently don't care that
much about that and also they're not
trying as hard to dissuade republicans
from voting the way they are from
democrats um so the the the night of
results are going to be skewed
because of you know counting of ballots
and so on and so on so
i'm going to vote i'm voting early but
in person probably on a
devil's night the 30th of october wow
well come on and join us on that monday
night before election
uh november 2nd and we'll sit around and
tell you what's happening in the news
can't imagine anything's going to happen
newsworthy between now and the whole
world
waiting baited breath to see this in the
election and whatnot and we will talk
about nerd [ __ ]
yeah we'll talk about anything but the
election ladies and gentlemen promise
you come back november 2nd it's going to
be the non-election
fat man on batman we will have a manic
monday yeah
it's going to be a good time um mando
monday amanda why is that day
monday on friday before that show does
it really oh [ __ ] you know what we're
going to be talking about next episode
[ __ ] mandalorian's back baby yoda's
back to save us all from this horrible
[ __ ] year
oh hell yeah save us baby yoda uh
yeah you're only open dude uh thank you
for hanging out kids go enjoy the rest
of your
weekend go sleep if you're back east go
watch sarah ain't live if you're back uh
wait [ __ ] what time is it
yeah you can watch it right now it's
well yeah we missed it because now it's
on like 8 30 remember when we were kids
and [ __ ] it was only on at 11 30.
now you can watch it at 8 30. yeah you
have to have like special dispensations
from your parents to stay up this late
like
severe negotiations like the yalta
conference to be able to stay up to
watch it live
excellent [ __ ] yalta reference
[ __ ] yalta yo at the end of the show
we pulled drops yalta
everyone's like this show is a little
stupid and then mark says y'all so
they're like intelligent humor i was
keeping my powder dry
there it is ladies and gentlemen go
enjoy your weekend we'll see you on
november 2nd man
uh for fat man beyond i'm kevin smith
i'm mark tune in next time same
fat time same fat channel spodcast.com
or youtube.com kevin smith uh for the
good of all cree
wakanda forever
you